les millions et vivent sur cette planète
depuis bien plus longtemps que nous ils
tentent tous des noms différents
dave carroll aux enseignants c'est
norbert de c'est un abruti
ils ont tous le même objectif servir le
maître le plus moche le plus méchant qui
soit trouvé un maître qui est plutôt
sobre mais le garder c'est là que les
choses se gâtaient mais malgré tout
au 100 m qu'il n'avait pas de culte il
était sans raison de vivre et déprimé et
si la situation s'éternise et il allait
certainement périr cède alors qu'un
million décida de prendre les choses en
main kevin était fier ce serait lui qui
ramènerait à s'attribuer le plus grand
le plus car il est méchant
stuart avait faim surtout ce serait lui
qui mangerait cette banane quant à mode
ils avaient peur de cette grande
aventure qui les attendait
un bijou matin pour la neumatt encore un
banana banana
alors papa qu'est la télé bell reconnaît
pas par ailleurs